isolation is seen as a privilege for
palestinian and syrian refugees in
lebanon
who have died from coronavirus at a
higher rate than the national average
along with migrant workers they make up
30 percent of a nation of 6 million
people
they are included in the national
vaccination campaign
that is supposed to give equal priority
to all
but many refugees don't seem to be aware
of their rights
[Music]
nobody came and mentioned anything but
if asked we would surely take it
government data shows only three percent
of those vaccinated so far
are non-lebanese human rights groups
blame this on hesitancy
little information on how to register
and the government
deviating from the national plan the
distribution by private sector has meant
that they don't have to follow those
priority categories
so you have on the one hand people who
are politically connected
or work for big organizations or can buy
the vaccine who have access to it
and then people like migrant workers and
refugees who depend
on the national plan who aren't getting
vaccinated
fast enough health officials say the
private sector is helping a near
bankrupt state
and limited supplies are the reason why
only two percent of the adult population
has so far been fully vaccinated no one
is
preventing you from registering because
you are a syrian or a palestinian or
ethiopian or whatever
if you are registered and you are
eligible to get the vaccine
one of the priority group no one is
depriving you from having an appointment
but for the hundreds of thousands of
migrant workers registering
can prove to be an issue they do not
have enough accurate and reliable
information on the different vaccines
the side effects
or any other information related to
their legal status given that a lot of
them are undocumented
and nothing has yet been communicated
publicly to give them guarantees that
they will not be deported or arrested
and they are not protected by the law
the authorities long accused of
corruption and nepotism
enjoy little trust many question how
they are distributing the vaccines
for example a donation of 90 000 doses
is being given outside the priority
groups
there is concern migrant workers and
refugees the vulnerable
won't get their turn if the criteria
established
is not followed senator al-jazeera
beirut